we all know that we are in the era of
globalization
and um and and and time will not uh
change so we have to adapt to that
situation but but but i think the the
challenges of the
previous decades like like the pandemic
like the economic crisis like the
migration crisis was what we are also uh
uh facing in hungary they proved that
the nation as a concept
is the only form
which can serve the interest of of the
citizens and of the community who are
living under the rule of that
destination
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
from the local studio right here in
miami and joining me today is the
political director for the prime
minister of hungary polish orban welcome
to the reuben report
hi thank you very much for inviting me i
am glad to have you here a freedom
fighter from across the way here in
america in the free state of florida uh
i was trying to think how i wanted to do
this interview because i will be very
honest up top i don't think americans
know much if anything about hungary and
i am not going to pretend to be a hungry
expert so i thought the best way we
could start this
was a little hungry 101 if i say to you
tell me about hungary
what does that mean to you
um i think all the people of
united states and florida would love
hungary because it's a
small but old
central european country with a thousand
years old
history
as you were referred
we
we are
known in europe as freedom fighters
because our history is about constant
fight for sovereignty we were
several times occupied by by by
foreigners like the ottomans like uh the
habsburgs so the austrians like the nazi
germans and the russians and
and and what we survived and um right
now we are proud members of
the european union and the western
community
but we have our own values and we are
very proud of
our nationhood our country
our traditions
and
that's the reason i think why
we came
part of the international debate at
least inside the western civilization
about the future of this civilization
which direction should we go
um and
if there is a dead-end street or not so
interestingly the guy that connected us
was my good friend pete pagozian who has
been on this show many many times who
you've met a few times now
and he's in hungary right now
and he is a
or at least was for most of his life a
lefty atheist but in search of freedom
in search of places where order exists
and western values exist and he lives in
portland where he's struggling to find
it there
goes to budapest and he's finding it in
hungary that that's interesting
he is a great guy um and
and you know it's
currently we we at least those who are
working for the hungarian government and
prime minister urban
we are conservatives we are christian
democrats we are obviously representing
the political right side out of question
but according to our understanding it
means freedom freedom of speech freedom
of thinking freedom of expression and
and we have to
preserve protect
uh pluralism in our society so if if
peter is there uh and and he speaks
openly about his uh views we can we can
argue we can debate with him
actually we are organizing debates uh to
show that
these are the alternatives let's let the
people
choose
and what he keeps telling to us that
it was the case in united states it was
the case
um in some other western european
countries but
but currently
this is not the case anymore leftist
ideology is just
one it wants to control everything they
want 100 percent power
not
separation of power so we send small
central european conservatives we have
tried to
um manage a political refugee program
for for for for people like uh
peterborough and and interestingly uh
most of my audience will get it you're
you then are called all of the worst
things right you're a fashion instead of
bigoted and all right i should mention
that although your last name is orban
you are not related to the prime
minister of victor orban no correct and
that must get very much no and it's not
the case that you have to change your
name to warbucks if you want to go to
politics in hungary yeah
so okay so you talked about the the
values of hungary so so what do you
think those values are i have a sense uh
from the way you described it but what
what broadly do you think those values
are
um i just came from
the conference of national
conservativism i think this is this is a
movement which is an intellectual
movement which is uh very close to our
thinking and the basic pillar of this
movement is uh
is um is the idea of nation
so
we all know that we are in the era of
globalization
and um and and and time will not uh
change so we have to adapt to that
situation but but but i think the the
challenges of the uh previous decades
like like the pandemic like the economic
crisis like the migration crisis was
what we are also uh uh facing in hungary
they proved that
the nation as a concept
is is the only form
which can serve the interest of of the
citizens and of the community who are
living under the rule of that
destination so so
everybody is talking about uh globally
globalized cooperation or international
organizations but but
and if there is sunshine and if there is
trade between the nations i can imagine
that
it can do good things um for the people
but but if there is trouble if there is
wind and and bad weather then you
you can only go back to your to your to
your nation to your own government they
had they should be responsible for
uh for you uh and and uh for for the
people who are uh part of that uh
community so this is the basic idea
uh unfortunately it's not very
trendy or mainstream right we're working
on it we're working with working on it
and
and
and you know it's not easy to talk about
uh god and and and and religion because
uh
because that's a personal matter but but
but still
we do think that uh these um
god and the idea of religion and and
tradition and
and the teaching with which comes from
from the bible through for example
christian democratic political
philosophy
it has to
play a very important role um
in in in building us a a
well-functioning society even in the
21st century so i spoke at a couple
panels and and gave a talk at natcon
last year and that was one of the main
things that came up that how do you
blend as as wokeness sort of infects all
the western institutions and governments
if the return is to be something of a
return with some level of religiosity in
it what do you do about the people
outside of that either the non-believers
or the gay people or
just anyone that is not within say sort
of the christian tradition as you would
see it and i know this is a big debate
no no no no
it's a it's a huge debate but according
to our understanding probably it's a
it's um it's it's different here in the
united states or even in poland
a country which is very close uh
to us in europe so so we are not
focusing on the on the individual
uh belief of the people because um it's
a freedom of decision if you want to uh
be on board if you want to take it if
you want to be a believer if you want to
be an active churchgoer you can do so
um
you are
not allowed to be punished for that but
if you don't want to do it then it's
fine
but the
but the ideas the political ideas who
which are coming
from this this kind of uh
concept
they are
um they are useful like like
like you know
family is a basic pillar of society if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell